but you know, if you are only
determined by fear, you
probably know that from your area, if
you are still determined by fear,
doing something wrong or giving someone food
to get them upset on Twitter,
then at some point you will be
pretty paralyzed  and above all
then you are on the safe road to
mediocrity because the degree between very
good and very embarrassing is sometimes
narrow
when people are scared
then they don't come
up with ideas, some of which are really
for the bin  are companies
are but sometimes there is also a
really good idea yes and if you want to
be on the safe side you know I
say proper headline
proper photo proper text are
valium guest for the reader today
perhaps the busiest most successful
editor-in-chief in Germany in
recent yes maybe  Even decades,
the boss is from the time they
were in Lorenzo and we
spoke
three days before the
relevant research about Matthias
Döpfner, which was quite interesting for the media industry, came to light, so that was
not an issue then, but now we
just started talking to Giovanni  How about
hello Philipp and for a moment
for all those who don't see you that way
I have for many
years now because I also come from the
media world
you are somehow German Italian
you can say and I've been a journalist from the heart
since I think 19 and 20
years of age yes committed to journalism
and actually did everything
in the end a great television career and
a girlfriend great
career at the time yes well television
I was always more of a fence spirit but I
started earlier right with
a youth program in Bavaria where there are
always tasks because the  CSU wanted to
close the sow shop, as they called it,
and then in 1989, um, the
offer came to do three more 9
that was the classic talk show for me,
I'm
still there,
but actually I always wanted the
printed word  design yes and that's where
I started with my first
permanent position in
1986 and when I graduated from high school I worked for a
year and a half as a freelancer
and tell me about your career for the
very short words for the station
so where did you start and
I started with that that I  we
had to do a short-form Abitur
internship and I had
n't tried to get the internship and
something happened that showed me
sometimes it's coincidences and sometimes it
's people who
have an intuition that
help you tremendously in life that you
have to remember  so that you
can also give something back my math teacher
always says there's a practical circumstance
I think that's just right
for you at a local newspaper
in Hanover tabloid newspaper
and I actually wanted to do something completely
different I wanted to
become a psychoanalyst somehow or a manager
and then have  I did an internship for 14 days when I was
19. I
did my Abitur late because I had stayed seated and was
flown from school. So I
had a hard time with shoes
and
on the second day I
drove home with my scrap tires and
knew that it was mine  My job was like
a vocation then I
said straight away I worked for a year and a half then
I studied then I
wrote a book because of this book
I was invited to a television
talk show about what
a rightist
published at the time that
was 22 then  excerpts of this story were
printed and then a
book publisher could come up to me and say
you can’t make it into the book the
book was positive, I got an
invitation to a TV show
and
then the opportunity
to start there as a moderator and stuff like that
is then made step by step like
step by step and
my first permanent job then she
with all the trimmings was at the
Süddeutsche Zeit and it was an
experience that shaped me
like a first love
to this day somehow like that
one of the platforms where you can become so big,
of course, yes, I
still don’t think it’s a very good newspaper,
and oh, you know what the strangest
thing I did was I
wrote my master’s thesis about a
media mogul who then had a pretty
big political career  made namely
silver
and then the prime minister and
so and for him then
offered me that I was there and
my workers researched that
I really become his personal advisor
yes
and so I asked my
girlfriend at the time about me  to
apartments in Milan
and so I came home one day
and said and I was
n't even in politics but only an
entrepreneur yes I said you that
's just not my world there are too
like in an American serial
about which  I'm not an oil potentate with all its
intrigues and machinations,
and then I went to the editor-in-chief of the
Süddeutsche Zeitung and
said, um, I have this offer,
but I would much much rather
work for you and if you didn't know,
I'm with the Süddeutsche  but
I almost went astray and
would probably be very rich today
or in prison or both
but you can say that at the end of the day
Dieter von Holz I think I
played a big role
I
worked as a reporter for Süddeutsche then I did
managed the one side that I still love very much today,
page 3, that the reportage side
or southern German had three four
people only in the editorial office and then
suddenly came an offer don't you want to
run stupid for a whole time and I
found it difficult because I  crazy about
Munich now and then the
southern German and then the manager
who conducted these negotiations
told me we still have a
wonderful they must get to know each other in our
publisher
that was then today there are two brothers
who run the company then it was
bring the elder Dieter von Holz,
we met in a hotel lobby in Munich
and then there
was only one
photo of him, a passport photo, which had been published in America,
on which it is difficult to see
that I met him, but as
I said, I did  First of all, I'm happy that it even
exists
and when we are very good at humor
and then broke up,
I said that would be really great,
by the way, if we kept it completely between us,
also because I
haven't decided yet and if I
go  I would would rather
say it myself and then he said do
n't worry I don't really exist
like that and then that was the prelude
to the fact that she then spent five and a half years
at the Tages Spiegel in Berlin which also
exactly like the time became
Stefan of training exactly  and in the end
it's a bit of a very
close relationship you take that was
between you and the gentleman and
bringing wood because he's in the background but
you're doing it for him I'm supposed to do the job
but that's a very grown
relationship too and  or a nice
relationship after the time at the
Tagesspiegel and which of course
has also become more and more personal if we have
you mastered the very big
challenge or generated a
lot of growth, a lot of economic
profit
or as one of
organized than one of many yes good
but already leading at least
tagesspiegelzeit in Berlin and then
within the organization then asked
to leave at the time exactly that was
18 years ago
are unbelievable periods of time I
also name the numbers because
colleagues can sometimes
be very jealous yes and I remember that’s
how it is  so there was a meeting
or message in connection with my
person where it said between the lines
the man is quite bold or
he always goes right before I before there are
any measurable results
and that's the proof yes I've been with
I don't know 34 years  three
past nine and for 18.5 years at the
time so mega leap power
before we now get
into all the daily questions
how have things changed in the
time business so we
will talk about the time success is a
little bit that you put it there
but it  it's already a
different industry it's
actually all changed and and
yet we tried very hard to
push the changes forward at such a pace that the people who
are connected to us, who read us, went with us
and so and there that  then there
was so much simultaneous movement so
maybe you got the feeling it has
n’t changed all that much but we
have changed only with the people we went
along with it I believe that
no matter what you do you should never
renew something like that with a product  there
is that those you no longer
feel comfortable do
you think about the media or especially
the time very strongly as a community so
I always believed in northern Germany
and at the beginning I think it was rather
smiled at we
introduced a time laser parliament, for example, then there will come
there were people from all parts of the
republic, even from Switzerland and
Austria, who attacked people at their own expense
and there were 2,000
people in the Audimax, so that you ca
n't even imagine why, to
see who is doing the time and then
everything was discussed  every
new project and also alternative ones and
also what drives us and what our
attitude to certain questions are
and then we have another I think it's a
really great program with meanwhile
I think 300 in the community of
350,000 people namely friends of the
time
and there tries a whole  wonderful
colleague who, like me,
has a bit of a migration background
janakis
is in constant contact with this community
about events and
offers that we make and
at the end of the day you make the magazine or the product
a bit for yourself
so you are the first, so to speak
Prototype of the community, so I
never try to be cynical, so I never follow
Benny's
approach,
so
a million can fly
is not always equal
to the mass of the solution and readers that
we have, and I think that’s
perfectly fine too, so if you
go by the cover photo, for example,
it’s often the case that in the
editorial conference when we’re
discussing our paper, the people  say some
say a really good beautiful title
from a look or from the line and
then I'm always so
tense inside because I think oh God then
it will definitely not sell at the kiosk
the titles where people
say what kind of presentation  Yes,
they are mostly running
pretty well, so there is a
discrepancy and that's okay,
but is that because in the end it's also
gut-driven by you or by people
not paying, you have
experience, that's quite clear and
I want quite  know exactly
who we write and work for but
ultimately it’s gut decisions yes
but look at how well articles
work online which also
just recently yes look at me they’re getting
to what
but for me it doesn’t mean
the articles click less in the
Interplay with the others
is not as important, so I think
when you start to act according to the motto
the only currency is
reach, then you give up part of the
reporting and with it a
piece of the identity of a newspaper or
a medium and how do you get that
People, I mean,
normally everyone looks
at reach and clicks these days
and it's incredibly difficult to get
rid of it when you say that you were both
authorized
to make an online offer where you don't
look at the clicks or at all  not that
would also be crazy, but if you
have the closed product, i.e. the time
at the kiosk or in digital,
then you make a kind of appointment
with your medium and then
I expect that we will make offers that will
also tempt people to read the topics
that you are referring to  would never have come on your own
and it doesn't matter whether they click or
not they contribute to the overall picture they do
a service to society
we also have to
illuminate areas that would otherwise
remain hidden and to say that is but
if it doesn't click it's not
important I think that's very nice what
is it
then come straight to the canned one then look at the
recipe for success yes it's sold
every week now we're talking about
magazines so about the printed product
so around 630,000 a week there
aren't that many companies in
Germany  whose products are
bought so often every week
together
I saw
separately at print again online
that you have 10 million users a month
that was something different so
we do or have our
online offer in the online offer are
also items from  the closed
edition but tell me the edition at the
kiosk you can find at the kiosk and that
came out again today,
we offer it to subscribers in print and
at the kiosk and you can also get it digitally in
different ways
if you subscribe to us and
are together  it's actually the 623,000
you just mentioned, so we've
grown a lot, so exactly the
same measurement in 2014, 110,000 less
that's true and that was very lost during the time when
everyone else in this segment was actually
selling news and journalism again  have a few
exceptions so nobody has these
growth figures
how does it work so why is it now at the
end it almost doesn't matter whether you read it as an
e-paper or have subscribed to or
we don't care either just tell me the
distribution, about 55 are still in print
and 45 digital is about the one that
we distributed, so
we also had that exchanged because at the
beginning when this high that is high
growth was suddenly visible,
I kind of had my doubts and
didn't think that the sales department would
somehow miscalculate
and no, that wasn't the case, so we then
asked over 5000 new readers or examined very closely why
and um and that was interesting
why they read the time, what they associate with it
and there is a characteristic, for
example, that we  we do
n't have any other sheet all by ourselves, we
let the competition measure it and
that's the word
diversity of opinion, something that many people tend to
shy away from at the moment because they're
afraid that different
opinions could also lead to controversy on Twitter
or who to shitstorms
we believe that they  that is an old
recipe that has always proven itself
that the confrontation not only with
other living conditions or
always describe that
other media also do this but also with
different opinions actually
only lead to the fact that you
can form your own good can form yourself
of course there is standboard  like
we don't have to look for and
we don't print them either extreme situation
extreme
conspiracy theories people who explain
climate change or the holocaust
you can write about them and
also warn the phenomenon about um now before the film yes
but they don't get a stage
but there is so infinitely one
political middle, there are so infinitely
many shades and if the media
commit themselves too much to one colour,
then I think they become more
boring firstly because they are breakable
and they also reach fewer people,
so you take my theory is without
them  can explain to you exactly how
the growth has come about over the last few years
my theory is that the the big
losses that there are, uh yes, in the
media reach also in television
and so that they are always easily
explained by saying it is  because
everything is changing because the
structures are changing structural changes
some things are true but maybe
it is also a bit because there is
a growing discrepancy between
those who do the media and those who are
supposed to use them I don't know if we're
still able and  We want to depict the
living environment of the people that we
actually reach well, if
then maybe because you
also have a clientele where
the readers and the
writers are actually even closer to each other
than we try, we try, but
it just doesn't happen by itself
also comes from these what we
want have described reader parliament
friends of the time so we try we
do a lot of events with
glasses and that mostly really makes
everyone happy because we also see
what great people they are but
still I sometimes imagine them
Question Most of us living in
big cities
have a certain
lifestyle, which of course
differs from the 50%
that we read who live in towns with
100,000 inhabitants or
are much smaller and the question
is not just for us but for everyone who educates
we really depend on their interests and their
reality. Do you believe that
this thesis
is a bit determined? The
awareness also applies to journalism
in the sense that 30 40
years ago successful
journalists were often rich people. You
can earn very well
nowadays  journalism is
often no longer so easy to make so much
money and that is why a certain
target group is no longer there, at least for journalists
or journalists, who
then simply do other jobs and then that
is to say, the journalists
are then still there, they then come out
by definition  maybe also
from a
mindset and from a corner that
maybe
something else is missing,
so I think the
average salaries have
gotten higher, thank God yes, in the top ones
maybe more was earned earlier,
but the money there has
also made it better over time, um, but  what is
certainly true is that those who decide
to become journalists today
he come from the
humanities also in the
journalism schools we have one we
run with that is the
country school
here in Hamburg we have hardly any people with
a specialist degree or lawyers or
mathematicians I want  also crazy happy
when someone applies to the journalism school like in the past
what in
the nurse I hired my
pages 3 in the Süddeutsche a
nurse who had
sent such fantastic texts and
we used to look for people in the
local newspapers in Bavaria for the
Süddeutsche there  were people noticed
or people in other professions and
brilliant public prosecutor who then
made a great career at the
Süddeutsche Herbert burned
or there were also leaders like
Georg Maske or
are still very present today but the Süddeutsche is
one of the best
journalists in the whole
German-speaking world  Raum who was
editor-in-chief of
Der Spiegel as someone who
had dropped out of school
just salutes the fantastic but I think that is
no longer the case today it is very
difficult to make a career when you
come from other milieus and with other biographies and that  narrowed in my
opinion and
not very conservative that's a problem that's a
problem for television I think if
you if everyone has to pay for a program
then of course they want to
find each other again certain opinions
and contributions that are broadcast there
the television
is already
[  music]
predominantly positioned differently so there
are statistics
at least that you can read now
I didn't check them in winter
but that's just what journalists do more often
vote for in the center left, so they do
n't have to write bad journalists
very critically about the Greens
if you do it yourself  green chooses yes but so
any narrowing yes if the
majority of journalists were FDP or
only CDU I find that I find it
just as problematic vice versa
so the magic word for me would be
saves diversity
and other issues journalism if you take
journalism out of my
wait then I think  from time to time whether it
could be that
the world has become even more negative or more
skeptical, so the world
as it is presented by the media is at least
negative, that may
ultimately be due to the fact that it
also has many problems,
but sometimes I have the feeling that
Structurally just very negative I do
n't know that it was very difficult to be
able to say subjectively
for 20 years like n right away, but it felt like
everything was a bit more
relaxed now it's like you put
on the newspaper or somehow go on the
internet and actually everything
[ __ ]
so there speaks such a really
an existential point yes how much
bad news can a person tolerate
right now in the past few years
first Corona
worldwide and then this terrible
war which of course also shakes up a trauma
or triggers it that
is hidden in their own families
were
never really
dealt with and I myself caught myself
in the first months of the war that
Russia instigated in the Ukraine,
that I had to process messages after 10 p.m.
although that is my job,
that I
said I would check after 10 p.m
no more messages because otherwise I'll
take the pictures with me into the night
and um and that's already points I've
never experienced before
ciao and surgeon
he can't start crying
when he slits someone's abdominal wall
he has to have a professional
distance like that  How does every
therapist
or people walk, but I
was
no longer able to build up a professional distance, so
I asked myself how are the
people who are supposed to see us or read us,
maybe even more
massively now, so we have at least
learned certain things  for me and that's why
I believe that today we
shouldn't cover up anything, nothing farmless,
so we have to bring everything that
actually happens in the world, including
atrocities, but we also have to use a
medium to depict things that
give people hope,
that give them courage, that
make them think differently  the ones where they
take something away that they say that has that's
an idea you didn't have before
and now that's something I
might want to look at too and and
another I got a different
idea of ​​reality
is because the world is over now  your point of view
and you observe it has gotten worse every day in the
last 20 30 years or
maybe journalism well we have
many years behind us where not so
terribly bad happened
if you now disregard the really big
global shifts such as the
climate crisis, of course, which was also suppressed for a long time
is the earth warming
but maybe the crisis was actually
the crisis is the normal case and the
quiet, nice, comfortable years were the
exceptional case these, e.g. Angela Merkel
has
whether she has become more evil Philipp no,
if you
look back from the past century I think they
have  the worst crimes in
human history have
taken place so far and um there wasn't
even RTL2 so
it's not that
often it's said there's just a
media or something no no no uh
people have taken the worst detours
and become capable of the greatest cruelty
too  without what is commonly
referred to today as the dumbing-down machine of speech, this also exists, so
there is a large propagandistic
manipulation industry that is dangerous
and which we can counter,
but there are also good media and
if we make an effort we can
really build up a countervailing power
you don't believe that it
is structurally the case that people or journalists
consciously often write a touch more negatively
because that also works better in the
online media in the end
because of course being scared with fear
also for clicks so there are structural
reasons why one also sees the world
negatively  considered independently of the
question of whether that is really right, so
if something unusual happens to you, then
you report it rather than
saying that everything went the same way today
as it did a year ago and mostly
it's also scary what
should we do if if  since I was
finally away from Lake Garda for a few days
it was such a beautiful day the
sun had written
I had looked at the water and then
the news came from the of this
killing spree
also near the the the the in the
area the in the  I live myself yes
and the Jehovah's Witnesses what should one
do but not report on it
yes or or just somehow
reduced it doesn't work either
but we are often told that even if we
talk to our own readers
it makes positive news
I find it to be doing  we also
partly online but I'm not so
sure if they are so crazy interesting,
but you have the feeling things that
were there many years ago in a different way are taking place
differently than, let's say, because they are
spread faster because  there are
fewer filters because they are immediately
online because there are cell phones that
get everything, so I think it's
more like one and then we
really terrible things happened, I
mean there's a war in Europe
that's kind of not a case like that
Civil war something else than
an attack on the sovereign state
I mean that and 800 meters 800 km away from
Berlin
that is something that we thought was
banned for all time yes and
you can see how fragile or how
fragile this prosperity and
peace order is  is which we have been able to
enjoy for 78 years now since 1945
there are a few other clues
I mean recently the woman
baker here was responsible for a whole
range of regional time
[music]
you see other things besides the
variety that you
somehow done right in the last few decades
in order to have this development
the capital of the credibility of and
earlier in independence yes
you must never gamble that away, that's
why I believe in diversity because
the more you choose one side,
the more you become
perceived as someone's voice, which doesn't mean
that there aren't situations where you just
have to confess yourself, so if
Trump is only a threat, then you
also have to say how things are,
but I just believe in the values,
credible because independent and um,
because you're from  none of the servants are
and none of the votes, but only
gives people a vote from time to time,
but collects different votes in the process,
you did
an interview a few years ago with Mr.
Gutenberg, our former
minister and
there was a lot of criticism  for this
interview and you were allowed to say so
that surprises me now because
actually it's still a
bit like that the variety yes well I
think I made a mistake there
because I gave the impression
that I wanted a catheter or
from  Helping Gutenberg come back together
and excupuring him that
was the way it was and that was mainly because it
was a book
from which the time to go out was
the interview itself I would always
defend I think I did my job
and
asked about everything  what every other
critical journalist would have asked
and it also had a great effect,
if not the one, if definitely
not the one that
Galtür may
have opened up about Guttenberg, but I would
simply say that was a
misjudgment on my part and
I also believe that  we don't give a
damn if we say
we're wrong and
certain things keep going
wrong and
mistakes will happen again and again, no matter how much a large part
of the day is spent on
avoiding mistakes, it starts with
spelling mistakes  on or near
lines that can be misleading
content that should
perhaps no longer be presented in this form
but do you know if you are only
determined by fear what that you
also know from your areas
if you are still determined by fear
what is wrong  or give someone
food to make them upset
on Twitter then at some point you'll be
pretty paralyzed and above all
you'll be on the safe
road to mediocrity because the line
between very good and very embarrassing is
sometimes narrow
when people when they  People are scared
then they don't come
up with ideas, some of which
are really for the bin companies are
but sometimes the really
good idea is there yes and if you
play it safe you know I say
proper headline and proper
photo  and proper text are valium
for the reader
so it has to be more
I would have felt this interview
at the time or this
development has opened the door a bit
or is a new element with
you people
that in the perception in the width
the big mistake  have made and
hopefully made mistakes
Uli Hoene or Julian Reichelt
often have
a chance
to explain himself to you interview that is a
conscious format for you now that
he says okay
we also consciously offer that because we
also offer diversity  in the end
promotes no it's usually just like that
if you take caves there is
n't a single one anymore whether Guttenberg
what the same thing there is no medium that
's not trying
to get then that's not like we're
saying we're offering villains
and  treat it quite nicely, yes, but
why
many then decide to do it at the
time is perhaps because the time
really has a very serious reputation
and because we also have a
newspaper that makes a critical claim
is lost every medium that
something like that is lost but one of
our core values ​​is
removing a minimum is sometimes
we can't do it either we've
had unfair
escapes but
we're trying to do it
and because we believe that some driven
hunts in the city find it
terrible too  So are
Christian Wulf, for example,
we just didn't interview him, so
I'm on the neutralente now, so for
two years, two months, it was
basically just about chasing
alleged misconduct on the
most ridiculous things, no,
that was a that  was somehow
a collective state of emergency at a
time when there were dramatic incidents, the
euro crisis, for example the
civil war in Syria,
and we dealt with
some
bobby cars and stays on Sylt and
values ​​that paid at the end of the process
then went  it was an unexplained bill
I think amounted to 70 euros
and I found that rather terrible
so if that's the example we
have at the time although we knew
that I would sell Christian Wolf titles
like sliced ​​bread we didn't have a
single title as long as it was there  still in office
was made in this slanted position about him
only afterwards
it would be that the example for them
was also unfair so that the example
just wasn't so
in hindsight we should have done it differently
we also sometimes have criticisms in the
assessment of people where  I
then also the car or the
author question would you like it to be like that about
you so yes imagine you
are so quick to read me that's about
you you just have to
realize that because that's a
strange contradiction
we are sometimes very hard  and also
self-righteous in our judgements, but we
ourselves died with glass jaws and are
terribly affected when we are
criticized, that is precisely in
attacking the freedom of the press,
yes, if one reaches back
and so
it is very important to most of us
that we keep a minimum  maintaining fairness maintaining
especially when there are battues there are
others that means excuse me
that doesn't mean of course we write
something nice about Putin yes that would be absurd
what is the reason why you do
n't play along on social media at all
well you  I have to imagine my life in such a way
that I
receive maybe 100 messages on a rather quiet day, yes,
different colors,
e-mails, calls, letters
and we try to process them in a
desperate race against time
and if
social media is added to this and you
accept that  Seriously
then I think the point has been reached
where even someone who is really
used to working is going crazy
and now there are
two other things
I'm
already aware of that it's a
fantastic channel to reach people like that
though I have so and  the feeling i'm
not totally invisible you can't
say even if i don't use it yes
and that's the third i think you only
have a certain function
then you have
regardless of what you do you have
your haters
and they you that's yours
Complaining about life, it just has to be,
most of the people who get this news
also suffer from it and that
I saw myself at least is just a projection
because I haven't done anything,
just because my
name is Giovanni Lorenzo and I'm
allowed to manage the time, I'm on her  already
an enemy and other people
consciously want to misunderstand me and that
only lives from the fact that one
assumes the worst of the other what
gain do I have from this what use
apart from the fact that I wear myself out and with
you in a daily work routine
from early morning to late at night anyway
living from communication you have to
imagine that you at least
look passively at Twitter from time to time, so to speak,
more than many of my
colleagues are right, catch them again and
again
and and
[music]
being active on Twitter at the beginning
we did that  now it's so that
we tell one or the other you ca
n't express yourself like that without the whole
newspaper being liable for it so
that means it's about restraint
yes and other platforms so I mean
now for the new generation it's
still tik tok a lot  more important so I live
a knowledge contradiction I am very much
in favor and that is one of the first also
required that we get involved we
do tiktok as time and we are also
very present on the other social media so on
the one hand
I promote it  and also thought it was
very very important but
I don't really expose myself to it but
you don't have to have a feeling for
these things and then also for them
exactly I hope that they have it
because of my family constellation
and
I it's not being active myself does
n't mean for me not being on the road a lot
and have you already looked at the brand
new thing Chat GPT I've
already had my my awakening experience NIS
that was so it's then
tasks and the awakening experiences
the  others have been sent to me
and asked what do you think or did I
say I need a little time to
move their own judgment and then
I
recently experienced something that
of course already touched me to the core,
namely at the end of November
a book is supposed to be published that  my
interviews from the last ten years, which
also bundles part of it
and
there were suggestions from the publisher for a
title that I didn't find all that great
and we always thought about what can be
done and what can't be done and
then I have with a friend
started
and I'll tell you almost every suggestion
was better than what I'd
read up to that point the punch line that
's okay for the time being, at least here it
is at the end we've
decided on a title, yet
it came out of our own heads and not
his  the k.i how draws it will mean
about life and other impertinences
okay and so that’s the one who didn’t have the
little joke we’re putting
on that didn’t have it are
you worried about
what will be possible with genitivity in the near future
so that’s now  Yes,
one thing that only affects you in part,
but generally the whole species
Belly out for us just
means we still have to get a lot
better than we are when we
try to be because
who pays the money when you can get so much
for a medium for a subscription
when you can get a lot easily via an
app the  then I know now
if you need a certain form of service
at 79 euros that every daily newspaper is more expensive
and you have to have excellence
and creativity and the mediocre
the routine that you got yourself
somewhere else are also
interested in technology topics I
have to
so I waver  like you like you
probably also between
fascination and horror yes
and so
at the weekend I talked to a
friend who then I think quoted
Eichendorff the poet yes he used to be
correct who was probably a witness
of the first train journeys
and then probably on paper
should have given I didn't verify it
that's change there are
simply they bring so much
speed so much movement
that the human brain
can't cope with now I'll show you
just imagine how slow
the trains were back then and how  rarely and the
company drove through the most beautiful landscape
and so the human being can
adapt to the brain too
but I believe that the Kai
is the biggest change ever in
my lifetime
so I find him what busy
what means a lot it is unfortunately
unavoidable  to deal with him
but with Springer
but he also plays in this league
between tones
but tell me how is your look at
him so that is unavoidable is
also skeptical
it is impossible not to be so because
you see one too  big difference
in mentality also in the
societies yes we maybe have
too many concerns and questions with every
innovation that is also allowed
and the approach of these people who at
some point stand out and consider themselves equal to God
is that we do everything
and and see if we are still behind
anyone wants to hinder them,
we'll put them in the laces, yes, they have a
fundamentally different view, and uh, I
own the world and I do what
I think is right, and
sometimes I fire 25,000 people, sometimes I put them
back, sometimes I do
propaganda for Trump, sometimes I say  I no, we do
n't want to allow that, it's
arbitrary and undemocratic,
of course, like any form of real
will, and you can see that everything
does so in one hand, so with a
mask, Peter Thiel probably does
n't do as well as he does, so I don't know
a lot like but also at
some point
these people weigh these people wrongly
because you simply
say wait a minute
and that could just
not happen like that in Germany we
also tend to have one thing about
leaders
and movements compared to them
allergy at the same time, which is very well-founded in history,
many in Germany now wish for
at least economic success and
similar companies that may then also
produce similar figures to you,
but you don't have to if you
complain about what is really deplorable in Germany, you don't have to
spend a lot of
bureaucracy at the moment  small
entrepreneur kills yes I know that
myself from my own circle of
friends and acquaintances and if you
complain about what I am doing that the Germans
have apparently largely given up on their infrastructure, so
in any case the
flawless functioning that is my
trademark was Germany for which
this country was admired  the trains
are on time
appointments and times are kept
so with important construction projects
I recently caught myself
arriving home in the evening and my
partner says you were going to
Berlin was on time today
so I didn’t want to joke
[music]
that’s normal it’s that  I've
just come from I drove down to
the to the port so in the middle of the
city that's the dead spots where the
where the phone call was interrupted
we don't find that particularly outrageous anymore
so you don't have to be there for it by a
long shot  that Musk is
allowed to do everything he wants, are there any
leaders from Germany in recent years,
maybe economics, at the end of
politics, that made you very positive as a person,
I liked that, there is someone
or has been or is currently
positive or not  who
somehow always bang on everything that
takes responsibility and
mistakes that some
media might make that's too
quick to bang on I'm happy
that there are people who are willing
to take responsibility I'm also
happy that there are politicians who do a
little something  and expose ourselves to this
torture we are in parts a
terrible profession yes what do we want the
alternative we want to leave it to the
unscrupulous stupid
interest-driven own cause
in this respect it is basically first of all
a forbearance because
whether there are idols there now it is too
strong but
since then go  First of all, I follow you with
Helmut Schmidt, with whom I
really had the gift of
being able to work closely with him and being
able to observe him up close,
but he was also very wrong
in assessing political
phenomena, but he was certainly one of
the when he  recognized something as right
is also tried to enforce
without constantly taking into account
whether it also does justice to the mood of the day
but is something different than Musk
Schmidt was democratically legitimized
somehow different that you can think of what
if you
are
so I think I don't know them
good you find them but very
impressive
sometimes I don't understand their public
statements because I think they're too fast
but I think that's Fridays for
future there are of course good and I
also know how to move and this with
my older daughter she
goes with and  thinks about it
and she doesn't have such a
personality cult that she now says she's
a Crete or Luisa Neubauer, well, but
[music]
we can't put these people in
such a high position either, because they can only
fall down, yes, they have, they have
an important function but
they are also flawed and if
you manage not to make too many mistakes
then they unfold a major
political effect I also find
Habeck's language regardless of what
I now choose myself I find it
impressive that brings in something new
yes
and it is
clearly different from the one
we are used to speaking if you are
also per se well what Matthias
Döpfner says that he says we
now want to build the largest media house in the free
world and really attack your USA
media is that that you where that
man  that's desirable
uh you can't ask me
that someone says
maybe our papers wo
n't exist any more soon that I say that's I
think it's good
and I do
n't just think it's right, it's also
dangerous
that they tell me  say this general statement
if someone directly as the owner
influences the political line of
their papers
okay
it is sometimes a bit of a
pity that you think that you don't
have to share ownership
of what you have been there for too many
years yes  you brought forward
and created so much value
you also realize that and yet you do
n’t participate as an entrepreneur
[music]
so if I were to tell you I would
also like to be a partner or
the time is a bit pretentious for children
also because I  I have the feeling that
the publishers treat me very well,
but there was a case that was worked on,
but it also resolved itself.
I think if you want to own something,
if you want to be the owner, then
you have to say I will found something of
your own
and then it will be  it's nice when a
publisher gives something voluntarily or you
can't beg for it
no that would be kind of
naughty and again
our publishers treat us very very
well so I don't have the slightest
reason
to prove anything you
probably have the broadest most successful
or in  the widest most successful
podcast portfolio of all media houses you
have a great podcast
time crime all said very many
formats how is it done or will
you do it no, so I
really have very little merit there
except that I myself take part with a small
podcast then
have that
Yes,
I am, well, a lot of that goes to the
account of the onliners, also the editors-in-chief
of ZEIT ONLINE, yes, Jochen Wegner also
has merits and then it is the
people who do it, so Sabine
Rückert is a
gift from heaven for this medium, so now  will
their stories also be filmed he
has to
represent the unique mine
but my classic princess of the
old school and more old school does
n't work and suddenly on all channels
not only podcast we also do tiktok with you
and talked about it
works on all channels which is
a  Unique so what is not normal
and how can
I believe that she met
with my colleague Jochen about it
and then thought about whether they
could do something as a podcast and then
somehow the idea came up you are a
former court reporter and it  If there is
a magazine called zeitverfallen we ca
n't make a podcast out of it and then
it's
a fantastic narrator who can report from
an unbelievable pool of
stories that
she has partly reported on herself
and that hit her like a bomb,
I think  I would have never
expected the
general process
to organize such innovations with you, so if
I try that, it is indeed a
hobby that we I think a
good newspaper is a good medium at all
is a
permanent cultural revolution without
cruelty,
so we have, of course, we also have
needed a jolt so we
also looked to New York, we
saw that the New York Times did this
uh think 10 years Innovation Report
where the uh the
editorial staff developed the publishing house itself
where the weak points
are and where the strengths and  what
treasures one could salvage and we
also had an innovation report
made by two
colleagues, one Kunze,
who is now also
involved in shaping time crimes, by the way, and the other
martinik the editor-in-chief is
between the Viennese standard we have
already gone their way
and  then, as a consequence of
this
innovation report, we
started to form teams from all
departments
man woman print online and publishing house
editorial department and they have those who are
there to examine our organization
and see where things are
not going well and why it is not going well  good
and
maybe people open up to them
more easily than if they would talk to me or have
a meal with the manager
and then also see
what would be the solutions and very often the
best solutions are those that come from the
editorial team and if I
find them then I always do  uncomfortable when he
gives advice to the other houses but that's what
I wish so much for
public law that
they're under attack that they start
not only what I think is good because
so a report made from the outside
they had people check how
the atmosphere in the house has just
been published, but that there are such
reports from the from the houses
themselves from the employees themselves,
the employees and employees
usually know very well what is going wrong
and what could be done better,
very briefly, there is
now  So a future council for
the public broadcasters is, among other
things, but also
various lawyers
I would have thought it's actually
the perfect job for you you're now
the yes then not perfect in
how should quite the opposite because
I should myself but above all
my colleagues
write about it at the time when I'm
involved in a process myself, so
I that's the difference you could
probably contribute a lot
because it transforms a medium with whether
I could contribute to it but it's
no coincidence that there are people in there  sitting
in the now have no direct
operational responsibility for the media because yes he
should have been
in the current situation there
is quite clear I could not what are what do
you think is the future of
public service if you have been working
for years for an end  you know
I'm kind of a broadcast for
broadcast as a presenter or but for a
century I haven't been
in one of the radio Bavarians anymore
no or in another one well as I
said so now I took the liberty of
asking one one one  Expressing a wish like
that is that from the
institution itself that wasn’t so
afraid of
admitting mistakes to face the criticism I
would like the
public service to
get off the defensive for once but that’s
changing  must that is
inevitable especially plenty the
alternative is such a strong
damage that is public
law as in America is hardly
noticed or just political at some point
if he do it's completely gone
and I'm very attached to it on the
public actually that's exactly why
I want it  change is
a bit so operational for you so
you wrote you
made this report you are trying
to create this culture that you can make mistakes
too
I hope so much that it will
be perceived that way flat
hierarchical structures very strong
team spirit a lot of independence in
individuals  Giving departments and
intervening if things go wrong but
first of all trusting that a lot of
good design and good content comes from the
people themselves,
you do that here absolutely
absolutely but I also do it a
gut I wouldn’t have so much
Tools that's why I thought that you
should use tools or processes that you can call it and they say that's how
we try to work on innovation
we us it's a
tool so my questions also the mood
of the employees from for example time
online uh not so that we say
it now depends on the
arbitrariness of the managing director
chief editor whether something like that
is allowed to express itself or not we try
to create as much transparency as
possible, also through regular
consultation hours for the entire
workforce, and yet there will always be
an accusation that I don't get enough
with them, maybe even with
you, even though all your walls
are somehow transparent for glass and  People in
the big rooms there will always
be people who say I don’t get
what’s really important uh, do
you think that digitization as the really
big issue for society
today
is the bottom line positive or negative
are you
I think that digitization that
this  Question that
cannot be answered like that First of
all, digitization was simply a
big promise of freedom
and a big
promise of democratization Participation
we know that hasn’t disappeared in itself,
but of course we also see the
negative sides now, but the discussion is
pointless, we won’t
scale it back
I mean, even now there are no
types of regulation, Europe
is trying to lose itself a
bit there, as the continent
that regulates the most, I
would be happy if the good digital
companies here were more interested in doing something,
but um,
there is  one point then I am very,
very tough and also in contrast to many
others I think there is no right to
insult, rush and threaten so when
this this status that you say
we are such a social channel is
basically neutral
and we only give it
We are very little interested in the platform and what happens next,
it
was regulated in between, at least in the beginning, and without
the consequences always being particularly clear
and obvious, while in our
classic media we are liable for every word
and are constantly involved in some kind of legal
dispute that is  not
okay that's an imbalance and
would be insulting that's not an
expression of opinion that's a criminal offense
have you already given some thought to
this subject of mandatory clear names on the
internet
yes of course I even once
organized a very funny group together with Martin Schulz  who organized a digital
charter, a
majority was against the real names,
I understand that too, wherever there is a threat of
repression,
but again that the privilege of
being able to express yourself anonymously does not mean
freedom to use any form of it,
so the answer is
clear names  Light is definitely clear,
so in any case the obligation to
put out or
put out what identification features when
it comes to criminal offenses do
you track the German digital newspaper
wants a lot more German digital companies are
tracking that now so that I’m
super competent now what he’s tracking but
I also know how how look  with AI yes
that's just an example then
otherwise that's beyond the scope of
this this podcast is but ever
AI how hard could keep up with
know-how to develop something of our own
but alone because the
data protection we have do it
Developing certain
programs is very difficult, if not impossible, and
we certainly have a
competitive disadvantage there and in some
areas data protection goes
too far even for me, but again that is an issue
we have to discuss about it for a very long time,
but the higher I am from the
entrepreneurs, the very
would probably be able to get in now there would still be
time to get in i don't know if we
have the prerequisites for it so here
was christian the jonas andrulis from
a company called alpha is somehow
so that the german
pptember is there he says that too by the way
he said that too  so
others also call it only recommend it to me
privately that's why
I don't want to violate the protection of sources now
but you hear that from
everyone and I don't think it
's a self-pitying protective claim in any way I think we
have the opportunity to do it and close it
many disabilities I have my
very specific question I'm
probably an economics specialist if at all then and I
really
enjoy reading time sometimes as a girlfriend
I'm surprised by the articles he
writes where you port to when your company
or entrepreneur and the sales don't show
up  or the result of this company
and I always try to
get that out here and then sometimes
write great that you always
ask something like that that's actually the core it
's a mistake if you don't
write that in the article or the
sales or bigger
clear  Answer yes
[laughter]
well I also want to know the age
of the people we interview then
sometimes forget
and how big the company is at least that
much older that's
amazing it's not an issue of
transparency, I don't think it's
written about it but
possible exact  Exactly
exciting, but how big is the shop now, well,
okay, so I have
one more important personally
important information at the end, yes, in
the sense that I think there was a lot,
I didn't forget something
important to ask, of course, but we can do
geopolitics  speaking are you
worried about the world currently more otherwise how
long will it last because the Portugal
of course would no longer be worried what is
the most
geopolitical so the longer this war
will last but really we are going to make
another almost um the more
we will too  realize that we in Europe
might then also be left on our own
I'm not sure whether the
support here in this conflict
but also in others will continue
if, for example, Trump comes up a second time or
someone similar to Trump
comes along and even Joe Biden, who might do that
making it gentler and
finding friendlier vocabulary for it
was also he will
not
want to face every conflict in Europe for domestic political reasons is
the issue more serious for you than
the issue of climate challenge
no no but at the moment it is of
course even more acute than the other
at least you can  Climate we have
a lot, we do a lot even
founded a department and allowed to found
another deputy Bernd
Ulrich, I mean I can already
tell that he has a great deal of sympathy
for which the activists in this area also reveal an
unusual amount of insight
for journalists actually well I
said it before we the
spectrum at the time is very wide,
just from Harald Martenstein the
colonist that is to Bernd Ulrich
who um in ecological questions and then
and the question of how to combat climate change
a very very  strong
profile has something for media list
online list also with i still have
something so you know if you read three
four daily newspapers a day i am a total
literacy junkie but everything german
no no can not
read in german language maybe that comes
from k.i
um  and I also keep reading
stuff from the New York Times or
articles that you feel like
you need to see and read by now
so I read way too much and but I
try
to read a little bit of fiction every night
because I otherwise have I  the feeling I'm
stupid there are a couple of tips here
for the listeners who might now say
that I'm still listening to what would be the
book they just put down
enthusiastically read is my
colleague Claudius Seidel from FAZ who has
a wonderful book  written about
the great journalist
and
with whom I was also a great director with
whom I was also
friends Helmut title great book
who made all the people's films
Rossini and so this
book also reflects a piece of
social history and that
's your exciting and this man is  just
a unicum but that's a non-
fiction book about or a biography,
so to speak, yes, some of them are so well
written that they are
also a bit literary, okay, we'll
take them with us, so I would
get that now, yes, the mug about
haemoditel,
yes, I think
something like that  such as forgetting the title very quickly
the man in white or is there read from the
first to the last line are there
actually people who will
get in touch with you and would you like a letter
yes that is but that was always
over very quickly because you want that no
there is if  So if you're listening here now
and can't get enough of
you, you can of course find a lot
on the net, but among other things, you
have to make a film about you, that's true,
that was a gift from Radio Bremen for
my milestone birthday
and that  you allowed it yes
I think that allowed it because things
were left out that were too private too
personal but still I was
very happy about
this film in the end and
that was maybe the moment when
I let it out more than I
usually do  done here so Italian
film so who is half Italian on it
but otherwise you will find relatively little about
the private
Giovanni I think
obviously appeal beidesign so
very intentional
questions so thank you very much for
coming around very happy
very happy user of your products
and also  a while you make room
yes i read that i have just
extended it has just been extended
yes so we want lunch when did
i try to persuade
you didn't know exactly now you have decided to think about anticipating
of course
such decisions are always made with
personal interviews  also connected
at home but now it has always
become quite long, yes, up to 5 years, that
means
thank you very much